hello readers today I'm going to be
talking about the skill of summary which
you might be familiar with in the form
of summarizing stories it's like a
retelling but shorter and in your own
words this is an important skill
summarizing fiction but it's not what
we're talking about today this kind of
summarizing is used when you want to sum
up the information in a nonfiction
passage like a magazine article a book a
news story a scientific paper most
scientific papers begin with a quick
retelling of what the papers about so
say you're a scientist and you
discovered a cure for Robo flu let's say
robots can get the flu first of all and
the abstract the summary retelling at
the very beginning of your paper about
your cure says hey under these
conditions we learned that this medicine
cures Robo flu and then the reader goes
on to look at everything else you've
written in your long scholarly paper so
how do you do it to make a summary you
will need your own words the order of
events or information from the text and
important details from the text so
what's not in the summary every last
detail from the original text I think I
first read something like this in a Neil
Gaiman novel but here's the deal
imagine you were coming to visit me and
you asked me for a map of my
neighborhood now if I included every
single detail in my map who lives next
to me every tuft of grass under a tree
it would stop being a map and just
become a one-to-one scale drawing of my
neighborhood in other words it would be
useless as a map a summary is a map of
my neighborhood with only the important
bits in it my apartment metro stop Rock
Creek Park when we make a summary of a
text we are in effect making a simple
map of that text and it's your job to
determine what details are necessary the
most needed like say somewhere deep in
that paper on how you discovered a cure
for the Robo flu you had written it was
raining on the cold the November day our
team first identified the Robo medicine
like would that be an important enough
detail to include in the summary I'd say
no the big picture is that the team
discovered the medicine not that it was
rain
when it happened but if the cure for
robot flu involved garlic and motor oil
yes that's an important detail because
it relates back to the big picture we
discovered a medicine and here's what's
in it
to conclude let me summarize a summary
is a short retelling of a piece of text
with only the important details included
it's like a simple map of a place you
can learn anything David out